Jimmy didn't have any juice around the
station it's not like he could go into
Kevin Weatherly the program directors
office or even Kevin and being ago
here's what we're gonna do file it's
like this go no or not so like we sit
and we go out to lunch or breakfast at
like noon because every you know we're
done with work everyone else is at work
we're like done and we just sit around
going what could we do like what what
what show could we do together no and it
was like at some point some other radio
station came calling and they're like
what we do a radio show on our station
and I was like me and my buddy Jimmy
Kimmel could do a show on your radio
station and they're like Jimmy's a
behind-the-scenes guy like he's a
producer he's not a talent you know like
you're the talent
he's kind of producer I don't see you
two co-hosting a show and we were for
bid for written for being on the air
together at k-rock because when we came
on together we like got each other to
boost up or something so nobody was like
you and Jimmy have to do something but
me and Jimmy were like meaning you have
to do something so then when you guys
created the man show the man show yeah
we were like sitting around and Jimmy
was like at the point of his career
we're just like starting to go out on
some auditions for like good morning
Glendale they want the perky host and
the guy was maybe at that point when
they flood now they're just syndicated
in Los Angeles but all the agents and
all the other people were out here Kevin
sit on the floor back then yesterday now
he sat upright at that stage in this
radio career and Jimmy was driving home
from one of these good morning Glendale
auditions you know and he said to me he
said they want me to be likable to women
and then he he paused anyone my wife
doesn't even like I said I know I know I
said how could we he said we forget
about being likable the women we should
just do our own show what's called a man
show like forget about what women think
when
win them over now let's just we'll just
lean into it you're on my girls but I'm
unlikable let's do the man show let's go
to mansion trying to make everyone happy
let's just lean into it no hard was that
thing to get on there then well that
thing was what hard right it was it was
funny because we it was originally a
pilot on ABC ooh and it was it was in it
was initially the ovations it was
initially a pilot and it didn't get
picked up by NBC but eventually Comedy
Central picked it up and then once it
got picked up it just kind of
immediately became Rogen was on the man
show the Rogen and Doug Stanhope took
over yeah yeah I never you know it's
weird I don't think Jimmy liked us being
replaced I went that way I wouldn't
either I just didn't have any thoughts
about really cuz that was cuz you guys
cultivated and created that thing I
would definitely feel sometimes I'd
probably be more in the Jimmy can't
there I think most people would I was
both married back then I wasn't Jimmy
was the I my feeling was we created this
show unfortunately we don't own the show
we created it and it's super successful
and it's they're gonna do a season five
and there's really nothing we can do
about it so that's it like I don't care
like I always think it's a bad kind of
use of time when like somebody says it's
sort of like it's like I work with Mark
Geragos and it's like he'll take a job
defending Scott Peterson and everyone
will go like you're such a piece of [ __ ]
you're defending a murder it's like
somebody's got to defend this guy yeah
and that's his job and it's it's weird
for you to not like the person like Doug
Joe it's like their phone rang and
somebody said you want to host the man I
don't want them the way yeah that would
host the show yeah of course and the
network is like hey man we're doing gang
Buster's in the ratings weren't season
four let's go to season five and the
producers are like hey that's a [ __ ]
cash cow like I don't know who to play
you guys didn't want to do it anymore no
we had I think what had happened I have
to get Jimmy's version of it
because I never sure how we were like
getting we we had completed our
hundredth show and when this show
started I came in and so did Jimmy it's
like a whole shitload of like I want to
do this I don't want to do that I want
to do this bit I want to do that bit and
by the time you do a hundred episodes
your honor you're like yes you're like
it's like it's like any band with that
first gray down because I've been
touring and playing bars and honky tonks
for ten years ever and then the record
company goes put out the next album six
months later it's like we know daddy
Tang talked to everybody else right so
it wasn't like that like the shows were
good and we always made sure they were
funny and we always put a lot of time
into them and we always really made sure
they were like the product was there but
like after a hundred episodes we're like
I feel like we've didn't have said what
we had had to say and Jimmy got the nod
from ABC to go host oh so late a host
the Late Show and which was a big deal
right because that's a big deal
oh gosh the biggest deal but I think
either you guys thought that would
happen right like that's I I was like
this a big deal this is a huge
opportunity and Jimmy helped me all
throughout my career and so Comedy
Central came to me and they're like well
Jimmy's gone but you're not you know and
then we'll just hook you up with Doug
Stanhope or Joe Rogan or whoever they
said to me you do the show any way you
want you you do the show alone you get
it another guy that fill in for Jimmy
however you want to do it we just we
want to do a season five because it was
a big blockbuster for them and they're
like Jimmy was leaving but no one else
was leaving all the producers and all
that stuff so I was like I don't want to
do that I did the show with Jimmy yeah
and I'd like to go you know with him to
ABC to like help him develop or launch
you know the late night show and we had
a lot of meetings and they kept one to
go out to lunch and offer me got like 50
grand in episode which was kind of a lot
packed and stuff and it just seemed
weird to do it without Jimmy obviously
and it's just something I never
entertained so do you think you do the
man show today wonder what that'd be
like pitching that I I feel like there's
room for it now I do too like guys are
hurting for something like that yeah I
feel like that is to see if is on the
you know if you're on in that flips
something you start you do it yeah you'd
have to get on couldn't be ABC or maybe
even Comedy Central but it had it go and
you'd have to kind of lean into it like
you'd have to make yeah you Archie
Bunker it's fine we know I doubt you'd
find the demos the demos what do you
think things change now that we've gone
through this insanity and we are going
through this insanity I wonder what I
always wonder what the ripple effect our
last question about man showing that
I'll leave you alone about it when you
and Jimmy we're doing that though do you
look back on it now yeah I'm when you're
in the moment you guys didn't realize it
was that the greatest time in your
career though so I think about certain
things I tried to smell the roses I'm
sure you guys had so much fun man you're
with your best friend if this huge hit
show you're doing what you want to do
that's how I felt about Houston this
weekend how much fun we had like you
said that sometimes go this is such a
blast to be together and just [ __ ]
laughing and being so in a certain
moment yeah but I'm sure that was
special
yeah our successful do Jimmy success you
guys both like these legends now but
what for you do you look back on that as
like a it was a big deal did you
implicit it was I mean you know you
never fully appreciate that like you
don't [ __ ] appreciate youth you know
what I mean like when you're 25 and in
great shape because you really stop and
count yours like now all right didn't
your body just wasn't in the way right
but you know at some point we had an
entire building it's like
me and Jimmy shared an office with
Daniel Kellison and it was like the
three of us just sat in a big office I
just had a desk that faced Jimmy's death
so it's like he was on that side it's
like one of those gay piano lounges with
the guys are going to both directions
again in the yang of the Wang and it's
like I'm like facing him and he's faced
me and I'd be like a man at acelino or
let a fart go you know no work no work
done and we got a rut we got a roomful
of riders but the riders are like based
on guys who want to hang out with like
everything's just dudes that are cool my
biggest I love men there are others too
riders we hired which were funny one guy
no still still working in my Adam de la
pena he came in and like guys are coming
like I went to Harvard and I was with
the National Lampoon and whatever and if
one guy comes in he's wearing a Hawaiian
shirt but it's kind of funky and we go
me and Jimmy like hey where'd you get
that Hawaiian shirt and he goes I made
it and we went you showed that Hawaiian
shirt yourself and like looks like yam
we like put the resume down and then go
and he goes you hire me I'll make you
guys Hawaiian shirts like you're India
there's another guy we hired based on
his softball skills because we'd play a
softball game at the end of the year
this is the worst we play a softball
game at the end of the year right and I
was like how's your softball game sick I
got it I play short stuff I got a cannon
for an arm I'm like okay all right
you're in you're in okay that [ __ ]
wrote no jokes the entire season [ __ ]
sucked wasn't even there half the time
and at the end we got to the softball
game and I'm like okay now you're taking
you first the guy suck and a wet noodle
Bernard I was like [ __ ] totally got
[ __ ] by this guy [ __ ] liar it's all
for your piece of [ __ ] but it's got to
be careful with how you but you can tell
somebody's funny with a comment like
that though yeah yeah weird bro once the
man show any kind of you and Jimmy going
your separate ways I've been a little
funky write it it's always like you know
most comedic team
end in tragedy I mean they just Martin
and Lewis or whoever they just end up
hating each other morning shows and a
hate for drive time you know I'm gonna
take two guys you put them together for
extended periods of time and tell them
to do comedy and I hate oh he said that
it's kind of what I was getting an
animal this is no Jim and I always got
along and and it was like I've always
been kind of philosophical about like
being a little bit behind the scenes
like I always kind of wanted to do that
like I thought I'm gonna sit at this
writers table and I'm gonna like write
jokes and stuff but it a certain point
it's like it's five o'clock it's time to
go and it's like Jimmy we need you on
stage to you know run the monologue or
whatever and I went and it's like hey
Adam go home and I was like okay like I
kind of liked that look I used to I had
a weird perspective on things like when
we do the man show and we'd run the
monologue like before we tape two shows
on like a Friday night or whatever it is
there'd be an empty studio the writers
would all just be sitting in the
bleachers or in the audience and they'd
have to watch the monologue see if they
had any ideas or punch up or whatever
and I remember just standing up you know
the clip the mic on you you're in your
sweatpants we do you have to go getting
hair and makeup and blah blah blah cue
cards and everything and I would look
out at the writers and they'd be holding
a beer and like eating a sandwich and
like [ __ ] around throwing a nerf
football around and I would think I wish
I was that like like I I know everyone
thinks oh you wish you were the one up
on stage but I'd see these guys drinking
beer and throwing a nerf football and
every going I want to be with you guys
not up here with the makeup and the hair
and then going over the cue cards and
stuff so I was always happy just to like
slide into the writers room yes right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]